How could the Church
not be interested in the construction of Europe,
when the Church has been ingrained
in the people of Europe for centuries?
The empires of the past invaded everything
and tried to establish their domination
by the force of coercion
and the politics of assimilation.
Your Europe
will be that of the free association of all peoples
and the sharing of the many riches of their diversity.
Religious fundamentalism,
which does not distinguish
between the spheres of faith and civil life,
is today still practised elsewhere.
It seems incompatible with the unique spirit in which
Europe shaped the Christian message.
Reconcile man and creation,
by making sure the integrity of nature is preserved -
the flora and fauna,
the air and the rivers,
a subtle balance...
Reconcile man with his fellow man -
by accepting each other as Europeans
with diverse cultural traditions
and schools of thought,
by being welcoming to foreigners and refugees,
by being open to the spiritual riches
of the peoples of other continents.
Work to rebuild an integrated and complete vision
of man and the world,
one that counters the culture of suspicion and dehumanisation:
a vision where science, technology and art
do not exclude - but call for - faith in God.
In responding to your invitation
to address your illustrious assembly,
I had before me the eyes of the millions
of European men and women you represent.
They have entrusted you with the great task
of maintaining and developing the human,
cultural and spiritual values
which make up the heritage of Europe
- and which will be the best safeguard of its identity,
its freedom and its progress.
I pray to God to inspire you,
to strengthen you in this great destiny.
Thank you.